this episode of real engineering is
presented to you by hover get 10% off
your next domain purchase using the code
real engineering when we picture scenes
from World War 1 we are confronted with
terrible visions of violence armies
equipped with modern weapons of
destruction converging only to shatter
against each other and collapse into a
war of attrition with both sides
cowering in trenches hoping only to
defend their lines and survive the night
desperate to break this brutal form of
warfare each side strive to find ways of
crossing no-man's land safely and
mankind's newly discovered talent for
flight offered a novel solution to the
problem but to say these early planes
were extremely basic would be an
understatement
these simple planes were primarily used
for aerial reconnaissance of the ground
eyes in the sky relaying information
back to the troops proved to be
incredibly valuable and the enemy
soldiers were keenly aware of this and
would often look up from their trenches
and shoot at anything that flew rarely
taking the time to try and identify the
plane as Friend or Foe leading to the
development of these iconic plane
markings to make their job easier
these early planes did not have the
power or lifter structural integrity to
carry any weapons more advanced than a
simple revolver or hand grenade in fact
the first plane to drop bombs in war was
to rumbler table in 1911 when an Italian
commander dropped hand grenades on enemy
positions in Libya this flimsy bird-like
plane warped its wings for control and
was capable of reaching speeds up to 100
kilometers an hour had a max range of
140 kilometers and saw some service in
the early days of World War one but was
soon at class by more advanced machines
like to be e2 3500 of these planes were
built throughout the war and were
primarily used for reconnaissance few
planes continue to use this monoplane
design in World War 1 for two primary
reasons the low power engines available
at the time meant that airplanes flew
slowly and thus the wings generated less
lift less lift means the plane can carry
less load so how can we increase the
lift without increasing the speed the
primary way we can do this is by
increasing the wing area modern gliders
fly very slowly and so need a large wing
area and they do this by increasing the
wingspan but making the wings longer was
not an option for a world war 1
airplanes because lightweight material
is capable of withstanding the bending
moment
long wing did not exist so to increase
the wing area and maintain a shorter
structurally sound wing the plane
designers instead created two wings
stacked on top of each other this
increased the lift of the plane and even
had added benefits as the second moment
of area of a biplane is much higher than
that of a monoplane making them much
stiffer allowing them to make high G
maneuvers if you don't understand this
go ahead and watch my wire I beams
shaped like an eye video on top of this
a long wing decreases maneuverability of
the plane as they have a higher moment
of inertia a plane would a shorter
wingspan can perform quicker roles as
they have a lower moment of inertia
similar to how an ice skater will pull
their arms close to their body to spin
faster a shorter wingspan also reduces
the role dampening as a result of air
resistance planes like the Fokker dr1
flown by the infamous Red Baron added a
third middle wing to shorten the wing
span again and allow for a shorter cord
the Red Baron is set up gained 80
victories in world war 1 partially due
to his shrewd tactics but also because
of the superior climbing and rolling
capabilities of the dr1
but each additional wing contributes to
drag and so stronger materials became
available and more powerful engines were
developed these multiple wing fighters
became obsolete continued improve all of
these aircraft allowed their total
weight to increase and soon heavy
weapons like machine guns were being
attached to the aircraft the cowboy days
of the pilots taking potshots at each
other with their revolvers were over and
a new era of military aerial combat was
born the introduction of machine guns
posed a new problem the best way to fire
at an enemy aircraft is to shoot in the
direction of travel but you risk
destroying your propeller doing this so
new designs of planes began to be
developed to mitigate this risk pusher
planes like the FE two became popular as
now he could shoot straight ahead
without worry of hitting your propeller
but the crew had best hoped that they
didn't drop anything and risk it flying
into the prop behind them other is
mounted the gun on a rail on top of the
wing allowing the gun to be lowered to
make reloading easier but the most
ingenious solution to this problem was
the synchronisation gear first patented
in 1913 this original was a rather basic
device the trigger was literally stopped
from firing by a calm with two lobes set
180 degrees apart which was directly
timed off the drive shaft to match the
propeller passing later designs were far
more practical but I will leave that
topic for another video at
stage planes were becoming effective
weapons in themselves and the battle to
gain air superiority was well underway
no period highlighted this more than
bloody April I am by no means a war
historian so here's my friend Indy from
the great war Channel to tell you more
about this battle thanks Bryan bloody
April was the result of the large-scale
British offensive on the Western Front
that began April 9th 1917 now it was a
clash of strategies as much as it was a
clash of Technology the Germans had
found themselves outnumbered in the sky
for much of the war so they were more
focused on defense and actually keeping
their pilots alive but they were also
always focused on being ahead with their
airplane designs so in 1915 they had the
fokker eindecker with their
synchronization gear or in 1917 they had
just gotten the upper hand with the
Albatros d-iii the British had not
upgraded their planes significantly
since the Battle of the Somme in 1916
still they needed to get a lot of
reconnaissance for their plant offensive
and deny the Germans the same thing so
they were much more focused on the
offensive compared to the German
defensive doctrine by the end of the
month by the end of bloody April the RFC
had lost 245 aircraft with 211 Airmen
either dead or missing and 108 becoming
prisoners of war the Germans inflicted
these losses at a cost of just 66 planes
making for nearly a four to one kill
ratio after that though the British
would upgrade their planes significantly
again and introduced the legendary soft
with camel for example a great plane but
apparently really difficult to fly
because of the rotary engine so you
needed a whole lot of training before
you could properly fly that fascinating
stuff right Brian
absolutely Indy it's pretty clear the
rate of technological progress during
World War one was not always matched by
the experience of the pilots if you'd
like to learn more about that battle or
World War one in general be sure to
check out the Great War Channel indy
brought up a really interesting point
with the software camel while it was a
fantastic plane it required an
experienced pilot while young
enthusiastic volunteers who were in no
shortage drawn by the romance of flight
but experienced pilots were far and few
between this was one of the reasons
Germany was so competitive during bloody
ape
as they focus much more of their time on
training new pilots
whereas Brittain focus more on numbers
with planes like the Sopwith Camel an
experienced pilot was vital to flying
the plane effectively the Sopwith Camel
used the rotary engine which works in
Reverse to the way a normal engine works
normal airplanes have their crankcase
bolted to the airplane and the prop
attached to its crankshaft but rotary
engines have the crankshaft attached to
the airplane and the propeller is bolted
to the crankcase so the entire engine
spins around the crankshaft rather than
having the crankshaft spinning inside
the engine rotaries had a superior
power-to-weight ratio and had superior
torque but they also gave the plane some
unique handling characteristics having a
giant chunk of metal spinning on a light
plane is not ideal as it makes for a
pretty effective gyroscope in level
flight the effect wasn't too apparent
but when the pilot attempted to maneuver
it would dramatically affect the
handling turning with the engine
rotation was quick but also forced the
nose of the plane downwards turning
against the engine rotation was slow and
forced the nose of the plane up
veritasium made a fantastic video
explaining this concept which I've
linked in the description the skilled
pilots took advantage of these traits
but inexperienced pilots often struggled
these rotary engines had weight
advantages over inline engines as they
didn't need a flywheel to smooth out the
intermittent power strokes of the engine
you can watch my video about steam
engines if you don't understand this
they also didn't need water cooling as
they were cooled by the air as the
engines spun but this had its limits as
power requirements increased over the
war as power requirements grew the
revolutions per minute of the engines
were growing and this meant the rotary
engine needed to spin faster and faster
the faster the rotary engine spawned the
more drag had had to fight against
making its power-to-weight advantages
slimmer and slimmer until the engine
type was no longer used by the end of
World War one the rules of war had been
rewritten and gaining air superiority
became crucial trench warfare began to
decline in use as planes and tanks were
developed across no-man's land
effortlessly these new machines together
created armies so mobile that they
allowed Germany to invade and conquer
countries faster than any army in
history in World War two we will learn
more about that in an upcoming
collaboration with real-life lore oh yes
thanks for watching the quality of this
footage is going to change dramatically
as I change from light into dark
and into light again but as you may have
heard we launched a podcast recently
called
show makers FM it's myself and Sam from
Wendover Productions and I bought this
site show maker starter theme of
hover.com who have sponsored this video
and have made my life a lot easier if
you've ever tried to buy a domain before
which I have with my real engineering
dotnet 1 you know how much of a headache
it is trying to just just get the
website without all the add-ons and
hover doesn't do that they just allow
you to buy the site few clicks and
you're done that's what I need recently
I've been incredibly busy between
traveling and everything else so they
have any huge huge help to me so I just
want to say thank you to them and I mean
if you want any sort of domain they have
it from a horse ninja pizza they got it
like literally they have all the domains
that's why I used them in the first
place was because they had Dada theme
and I couldn't find it anywhere else so
I used them before they were a sponsor
anyhoo oh wait no if you want to get 10%
off
go to hover 10% off use the gold real
engineering you got 10% off your first
purchase
great use it please anywho I'm going to
show you some of these these seams
oh geez tell you that is that one big
thing on my I need to get that removed
its column we're gonna call them Roger
it's the crack Roger why aren't you over
to close so we got friend on this trip
you